so sah man herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live ihre mit eurem aktuellen live
stream zu den nachrichten ereignissen
des tages
und da hat gestern nrw innenminister
herbert reul von der cdu doch mit einer
erkenntnis die öffentlichkeit überrascht
manche schockiert manche eben nicht weil
sie sagten wusste ich doch alles schon
und zwar sprach er von einem netzwerk in
dem eine jet gruppe in dem sich 29
polizisten und polizistinnen über jahre
hinweg ausgetauscht haben wollen und
dort wohl auch rechtsextreme nachrichten
ausgetauscht haben
dort war dann gestern bei der
pressekonferenz von herrn rolle die rede
von adolf hitler bildern von bildern die
zeigten wie geflüchtete in gaskammern
stehen also alles ziemlich schwieriges
und verbotenes zeug gerade für
polizisten und herbert reul zeigte sich
da gestern ziemlich betroffen und
kündigte konsequenzen an steht seitdem
quasi unter dauerfeuer dauerbeobachtung
hat sich heute morgen schon geäußert im
wdr und meinte erkennen noch nicht sagen
welche ausmaße das ganze hat aber und
das ist bemerkenswert
er sagte das alles sind keine
einzelfälle mehr das war bislang häufig
eher so quasi die linie der politik zu
sagen das kann man nicht als
strukturelles problem sehen da scheint
sich jetzt geändert zu haben und
innenminister herbert reul möchte sich
gleich im nrw landtag dazu äußern zum
stand der ermittlungen
wir warten darauf dass ich so etwas tut
wir können mal kurz hin schalten und
schauen was soll ich jetzt der stand der
dinge ist dort läuft noch eine andere
ein anderes thema so eben wie hör mal
kurz rein
es wird abgestimmt ein antrag ist
abgelehnt worden ich kann doch nicht
sagen welcher wir warten also quasi auf
nrw innenminister herbert reul wenn sie
oder ihre fragen zum thema habt oder
kommentare zu diesen ganzen schwierigen
komplex bitte gerne in den
kommentarspalten posten wir gucken uns
das an die ganzen gesammelten fragen
versuchen wir am ende zu beantworten wir
werden sprechen jetzt gleich mit
professor tobias singelnstein von der
ruhr-uni bochum kriminologe und danach
mit meiner kollegin dort bisher aber im
studio düsseldorf jetzt gucken wir
erstmal ob herr singelnstein schon da
ist für ein gespräch sie hören mich ja
ich höre die schönen guten tag
davon hätten sie beschäftigen sich ja
auch gerade mit diesem komplex
gesellschaft und polizei und quasi der
gesellschaftlichen kontrolle von polizei
wie überrascht waren sie gestern über
die nachricht des innenministers 101
zahlen über die nachricht selbst weil
ich eigentlich nicht besonders
überrascht wir wissen ja schon lange
dass es ein gewisses problem mit
rechtsextremismus und rassismus in den
reihen der polizei gibt ein bisschen
überraschend war für mich eher das
ausmaß also die anzahl der beamten
beamten wieder involviert waren und die
klarheit mit der herr da ihm die sache
angegangen ist
ich habe gerade von einem kollegen
gehört herold tritt ans rednerpult ist
das richtig ich muss mal kurz an die
regie fragen dann gehen wir jetzt einmal
rüber herr singelnstein wir sprechen
gleich weiter über das was herr
innenminister jetzt den abgeordneten und
abgeordneten berichtet hat dass er sich
auf das gros der polizisten verlassen
können
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren das hat mir
imponiert nicht weil ich da drin
vorkommen dass alles quatsch sondern
weil darin zum ausdruck kommt dass das
gros dass die große mehrheit der
beschäftigten in der polizei für 50.000
menschen absolut integer ist und
arbeitet mit täglich arbeitet für unsere
sicherheit und deswegen glaube ich genau
und sinne dieser große mehrheit müssen
wir die aktuellen vorgänge ganz sauber
mädchen und jeder vorwürfe sich
bewahrheitet muss knallhart konsequenzen
haben
extremisten haben in der nordrhein
westfälischen polizei gar nichts
[Applaus]
wer extremistisch denkt und handelt
verwirkt sein recht diesem uniform zu
tragen die uniformen die von vielen
tausend mitarbeitern und mitarbeitern zu
recht stolz getragen wird und jeder
einzelne extremistin der polizei schadet
dem ansehen der gesamten familie der
polizei und was ich da gestern gesehen
habe hat eine dimension und eine
abscheulichkeit den ich nicht für
möglich gehalten habe ich gebe das zu
und sie wissen das vielleicht oder
sicher aus der presse wir haben nach dem
aktuellen ermittlungsstand mit einer
gruppe von beamten und beamten zu tun
die widerwärtige menschenverachtende
rassistische gewalt verherrliche bilder
digital durch die gegend geschickt haben
und das über viele jahre
wir haben das erfahren und haben dann um
das alles auch gut vorzubereiten auch
gerichts vorzubereiten dass unter
strengster geheimhaltung gemacht damit
niemand von den beschuldigten seine
spuren verwischen können
aber mir war natürlich wichtig dass wir
sehr schnell und umfassend sie auch über
die sache selber aber auch über die
maßnahmen unterrichten
deswegen habe ich gestern morgen die
innenpolitischen sprecher der fraktionen
informiert kurz dabei in der kurzen zeit
mehr nicht möglich
hab natürlich auch angeboten dass
bildung über den parlament vorzutragen
habe dann auch gesagt dass wir im
innenausschuss next wochen natürlich
darüber
ausführlich reden aber ich bin froh dass
ich das heute hier vor dem ganzen
parlament tun kann
ich habe auch übrigens die
gewerkschaftsvorsitzenden angerufen weil
ich glaube das ist in einer solchen
frage wichtig und dann die
öffentlichkeit weil die dimension ist
verlangt dass man das präzise möglichst
präzise soweit man das gerne vorträgt
ich frage mich auch wie viele andere
warum sind solche gruppen früher nicht
aufgefallen uns nicht früher aufgefallen
er nicht früher aufgefallen
das beschäftigt mich seit dem tag
seitdem ich weiß dass es das gibt das
ging 2012 los es ist 2012 nicht
aufgefallen ist es 12.000 2013 nicht
aufgefallen zeit warum mit 14 bis 2015
nicht 2016 nicht 2017 nicht 2018 19 und
jetzt erst 20 und das macht schon sehr
nachdenklich
wir haben übrigens wenn ich bei den
jahreszahlen gerade bin 218 als
landesregierung erstmalig eingeführt
dass alle neuen an werken einer polizei
durch den verfassungsschutz überprüft
werden weil wir wollten ein stück mehr
sicherheit haben bin froh dass wir es
gemacht haben 2009 10 habe ich begonnen
eine wertediskussion in der partie
polizei zu beginnen da haben viele
gedacht der typ der spielt nein ich
wollte dass wir uns ein stück wollte
kann papieren und nicht wollte dass wir
uns verständigen darüber das wir
nachdenken darüber was trägt was
eigentlich die grundlage von polizei
weil ich auch das gefühl hatte alles
stimmt da nicht mehr und 2000 habe ich
dann 2020 also in diesem jahr hatte ich
schaffe der extremisten beauftragten
vorgeschlagen nicht weil ich glaube
damit wären alle probleme zu lösen will
sich bin zu lange in der politik um zu
glauben
simsalabim die probleme sind gelöst aber
weil ich glaube es ist ein instrument
wie man niedrigschwellig nah an den
polizisten da wo sie arbeiten eine
ansprechpartner organisiert also ein
bisschen hammer gemacht und da sind ja
auch einige fälle aufgeflogen wenn ich
war so salopp sagen davon haaren haben
gelsenkirchen aber wir kennen das aus
andere themen wenn man anfängt
aktiv zu werden etwas auf den grund geht
findet man etwas aber das gehört zu
ganzen welt dazu
offenbar haben wir nicht alles erkannt
vielleicht sogar die dimension
unterschätzt aber ganz so einfach ist
das eben nicht denn dann steht einem
ganz schön starken dilemma schauen sie
sich mal den fall von gestern an eine
private geschlossene check gruppe da ist
nicht irgendjemand mit einer
einstelligen in kleidung oder mit der
reichskriegsflagge dem auto in diensten
zur wache gefahren sondern es ging um
eine abgeschlossene kommunikationskanäle
über die wir jetzt reden und da gibt es
ein problem das muss man benennen ich
weiß da keine lösung aber ich will sie
benennen
das sind abgeschlossene
kommunikationskanäle und da gibt es
natürlich eine grundgesetzlich zurecht
geschützte eingriffsschwelle da braucht
man eine eintrittskarte um da rein
gucken zu dürfen
da kannst du nicht einfach in die handys
der polizisten reingucken
und wir hatten ja manchmal braucht man
das auch dass wir an einem anderen fall
der mit dem geheimnisverrat eines
polizisten eine grundlage hatten in
einen handy zu gucken
beim einst beim ursprungs verfahren bei
der wohnungssuche haben wir dann in
diesen handys ist diese jet-gruppe und
diese bilder entdeckt dann und das bitte
auch nicht vergessen
trotz alldem ist dann hat die polizei
erkannt da gibt es noch was und die
polizei ermittelt und sie hat
systematisch ermittelt und wir haben das
entdeckt was jetzt gestern zum handeln
geführt hat morgens ab 6 uhr wurden
zahlreiche richterliche
durchsuchungsbeschlüsse vorstellt
vollstreckt die sonderkommission babbel
war mit 200 ermittlern im einsatz 35
polizeidienststellen privatwohnung
wohnen gesucht und der vorwurf war klar
das versenden und empfangen von
rechtsextremistischer propaganda die
mindestens fünf privaten whatsapp chat
gruppen die aber offenbar ausschließlich
oder überwiegend von polizeibeamten
genutzt wurden
wir reden dabei willst du mal sein
ich kann die leute die bilder nicht
zeigen weil
tatsächlich geht wenn es die seen würden
müssten sie wovon ich rede
wir reden von übelster widerwärtigsten
neonazistischer rassistischer und
flüchtlings fand sicherheits das sind
weit über 100 bezahlt parteien ich
glaube die sind mittlerweile 160 geht
jede stunde weiter das ist nicht nur
hitler hakenkreuze reis ließ fragen
sondern das sind eben aus subjektiven
darstellungen mit flüchtlingen mit
gaskammern mit schwarzer hautfarbe mit
ach ich will es nicht sagen weil ich da
einfach auch kein präjudiz schaffen darf
aber es ist unerträglich dass alles böse
vorsichtshalber sagen mutmaßlich
versendet oder empfangen von
polizistinnen und polizisten des landes
noch das verein von menschen die
geschworen haben die verfassung des
landes zu befolgen und zu verteidigen
mittlerweile sind 30 polizistin
polizisten betroffen
ich sage bis jetzt weil sie erinnern
sich an andere themen
wenn man anfängt zu graben das kann noch
mehr werden
wir haben einige erkenntnisse erlangt es
gibt den verdacht aber eine weitere
beteiligte die ebenfalls in dieser
mülheimer polizeiwache gehört damit
haben wir jetzt 26 beamte die aus dieser
behörde kommen aus dem elgar einen dem
landes im dfb ist um zwei de/ml zb die
arbeiten
die allermeisten haben aber irgendwann
mal in dieser deals gruppe gearbeitet
also in einer gruppe die zu
polizeipräsidium essen gehört in mülheim
an der ruhr und du dass die meisten
jetzt noch alle diese 30 wurden gestern
suspendiert also vorläufig des dienstes
enthoben
gegen alle wurde ein
disziplinarverfahren eröffnen 14 davon
mit dem ziel der entfernung aus dem
dienst die mussten ihre dienstwaffen
dienst weise abgeben keine uniformen
tragen dienst gewahrt wurde darf nicht
mehr betreten wollen wir haben gestern
ungefähr 100 elektronischen medien aus
sichergestellt die müssen natürlich
detailliert ausgewertet werden und da
kann ihnen heute nichts zu sagen weil
gründlichkeit geht vor schnelligkeit
sind circa 43 43 mobiltelefone 19 usd
sim-karten 120 usb stick 20 festplatte
20 laptops und pcs an sich
die cds dvds neuen tablets eine dicke
waffe geringe mengen btm also da wartet
noch viel arbeit auf die die sich darum
kümmern müssen
aber das einzige was jetzt ja nur hilft
cool bleiben würde meine tochter sagen
nicht lamentieren nicht diskutieren
handeln und wir werden das aufarbeiten
und mittlerweile kennen sie mich
wir werden das aufarbeiten radikal und
bis ins kleinste detail 30
[Applaus]
im einzelnen geht es um im einzelnen
geht es um strafprozessuale maßnahmen
gegen zusätzlich gegen eine beamtin die
als lebensgefährtin eines als ursprung
nicht beschuldigten identifiziert werden
konnte und die auch mitglied des checks
gruppe wird gegen die macht jetzt
zusätzlich noch ermittelt das ist
gestern noch hervorgekommen weil des
verstoßes verdacht des verstoßes gegen
waffengesetze sowie verstoß gegen das
betäubungsmittelgesetz gibt für zwölf
beamte strafrechtlich ermittelt im 3
september wurde diese sonderkommission
errichtet das habe ich ihnen ja gesagt
und das einzige was an da man auch ein
feld wo man sagt gott sei dank und auch
gut dass die ermittler so schnell waren
das ist überhaupt bemerkt haben dass
sich gekümmert haben und deswegen möchte
ich mich gehört auch dazu bei denen
bedanken dem polizisten polizisten
entdeckt haben und sich darum gekümmert
haben und nicht wegen dann herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
so dass das ist die lage bis jetzt noch
einmal bis jetzt weil so debatten gehen
ja weiter damit jeder zuhört bis jetzt
das kann sich weiterentwickeln das muss
ich nicht weiterentwickeln ich hoffe es
wickelt sich nicht zu sehr weiter wir
haben daraus konsequenzen gezogen
die ersten die habe ich in vorgetragen
disziplinarrecht strafrechtlich wir
haben das lfg herrn früchten personen
beauftragt die ganzen ermittlung zentral
zu führen das wird jetzt nicht jetzt das
wird zentral gemacht und zwar alle
weiteren maßnahmen bekommen werden auch
dahin organisiert wir werden eine sonder
inspektion für die polizeipräsidium
essen machen weil wir genau schauen
müssen wusste da vielleicht doch nur
irgendeiner was ist da vielleicht doch
was vorgekommen bisher kein anzeichen
nach allen ersten ermittlungen aber sie
müssen wissen wir konnten ja weiter
verdeckt gearbeitet haben bisher auch
noch nicht allzu viele fragen also da
muss man einfach abwarten das ist jetzt
kaffeesatz wenn man vermutungen daran
stellt es hilft ja auch keinen weiter
wir haben zweitens entschieden einen
sonderbeauftragten rechtsextremismus in
der polizei nrw und eine dazugehörige
stabstelle zu errichten
ich sage ihnen auch warum weil ich
möchte eine ein ganz vollständiges
lagebild rechtsextremismus in der
polizei als grundlage haben wir haben
teile
wir haben im zusammenhang mit der arbeit
des bundesamtes für verfassungsschutz
schon bis märz daten nach berlin nach ja
im bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
geliefert und wir werden die dafür
zweiter akkreditieren und versuchen
daraus ein gesamtbild zu bekommen so
weit das geht bitte versprechen sich
davon auch keine wunder weil nochmal
stichwort geschlossene chad rupp
zweitens wird dieser beauftragte und das
ist das wichtigste ein handlungskonzept
entwickeln zu frühzeitiger erkennung von
rechtsextremisten tendenz zur prävention
er soll das tun auch unter hinzuziehung
von außen sachverstand nicht nur alleine
mit unseren leuten das kann wissenschaft
sein das können die menschen sein die in
der polizeiseelsorge sein und ich gehe
davon aus dass das auch in
zusammenarbeit mit den fachleuten der
fraktionen passieren kann zumindest hat
er die absicht auch die kontakte zu
wir haben gestern behördenleiter tagung
gemacht weil ich finde die sind jetzt
auch in größter verantwortung die sims
dezentralen dran die können das er
mitbekommen als eine zentrale und ich
habe die absicht die untere
führungsetagen in dezentralen
veranstaltungen mit denen selber zu
reden weil ich möchte jeden einzelnen
bäder irgendwo eine führungsfunktion hat
in die pflicht nehmen sich zu kümmern
müssen das kriegen sie nämlich nicht hin
mit allem was wir sonst immer der
politiker maßnahme
das kriegen wir nur hin wenn wir die
mitte wenn wir die beschäftigten
immunisieren wenn man sie nachdenklich
machen wenn wir sie zu helfern machen
wenn wir so etwas wie man hinkriegen
dass gesunde kollegialität was anderes
ist als falscher poker ist wenn wir es
hinkriegen dass sie aufeinander
aufpassen stadt abzuschotten
wenn sie will sie dazu kriegen dass sie
helfen wir brauchen eine neue kultur und
die können sie nicht verordnen da haben
wir in den letzten jahren also ich habe
mich darin wirklich schon bemüht aber es
geht eben nicht so einfach und deswegen
war ich auch so erschüttert dass solche
große gruppe wirklich da war ich habe
bei jeder gelegenheit versucht dafür zu
werben und zu überzeugen dass polizisten
nicht irgendein job ist bei den
vereinigungs feier die wir jetzt hatten
im verhalten habe ich den jungpolizisten
dieses kleine und gesetz gegeben
nicht weil ich glaube dass die leute
jetzt alles durchlesen oder weil ich
glaube die haben keine ahnung davon
sondern ich möchte denen klar machen das
ist eine persönliche hinweis von mir das
ist eine verantwortung nimmt das mit ihr
seid nicht irgendwelche leute in
irgendeinem beruf sondern auch die
verantwortung und der oberste satz heißt
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
das ist euer auftrag das ist mehr als
jeder andere beruf das weiß
anforderungen
[Applaus]
ich weiß dass ich von diesem dass ich
von diesen 50.000 menschen wahnsinnig
viel verlange aber das ist eben so sie
haben bewusst als die polizisten wurden
dass sie diese aufgabe wahrnehmen
wir müssen ihnen dabei helfen und
vielleicht gibt es da ein paar stellen
wo wir mehr helfen müssen als bisher
vielleicht hat der eine oder andere
polizist der in den schwierigkeiten des
alters war manchmal gedacht er dann doch
allein und der polizeiseelsorger oder
psychosoziale dienst wieder was wir
alles haben reicht auch nicht aus
vielleicht brauchen wir noch etwas mehr
aber lasst uns das bitte gründlich
erörtern
ich habe eine riesen bitte noch einmal
tun sie mir nicht mehr tun sie der
polizei noch zumindest denen gefallen
dass wir daraus ein gemeinschaftliches
projekt machen dass wir versuchen daran
gemeinsam zu arbeiten ich brauche da
jeden fall so zwischenrufe helfen dabei
auch nicht weiter aber bis mir egal ich
haben anliegen ich werde das machen und
ich bitte sie mitzumachen ich lade sie
ein mitzumachen
und wenn nicht dann mag ich das auch
notfalls alle hände wie bei möchte damit
das klar ist
[Applaus]
von der cdu der sich doch relativ klar
geäußert hatte ich fast noch mal ganz
kurz zusammen
neue erkenntnisse hatte einmal
mitgeteilt betroffen sind insgesamt
jetzt 30 polizistinnen davon 26
beamtinnen aus mülheim an der ruhr
nadine stähle und vier weitere an
anderen dienststellen die aber wohl
allemal dort gearbeitet haben sich also
irgendwie gekannt haben 14 beamtinnen
wurden aus dem dienst entfernt dürfen
also weder war von noch abzeichen tragen
keine uniform er nicht in die
dienststelle reingehen und es wurden 100
weitere elektronische medien
sichergestellt laptops pcs tablets
sim-karten handys festplatten nannte
herbert reul dort die jetzt ausgewertet
werden sollen
er wies darauf hin dass es sich
natürlich bei so einem thema immer mein
brief einem dilemma handelt in dem die
ermittlerinnen da stecken weil eine
private jet gruppe ist natürlich
eigentlich vom grundgesetz geschützt da
darf man nicht so einfach reingehen und
die hatten die ermittler in ein halt
einfach das glück oder den zufall dass
sie aus anderen gründen in ein handy
rhein gucken konnten und dann dort
diesen chat verlauf gefunden haben
er hat sich selber ein paar vorgefühl
gemacht kann man fast sagen ja meinte
vielleicht haben die dimension
unterschätzt er fragte sich warum solche
chat gruppen früher nicht aufgefallen
sind und die bilder um die es hier geht
können nicht gezeigt werden aus
verfahrenstechnischen gründen wie er
sagte weil das hat ein laufendes
ermittlungsverfahren ist er hat eingangs
aber auch noch betont dass er sich auf
die mehrheit der polizistinnen in nrw
verlässt und auch der meinung ist aus
diesem grund müsse man jetzt hier
handeln und nicht diskutieren
ich spreche jetzt im landesstudio
düsseldorf mit meiner kollegin dort
ferber nein sie steht vor dem landtag
oder sich richtig vor dem landtag
wundervoll dort du hast die worte von
herbert rolle gerade auch mit verfolgt
ist es typisch für ihn dass er gestern
doch so durchgreift oder wird es zu
sagen er hat so lange gezögert
also er ist schon sehr angefasst und das
gesteht ihnen sogar die opposition zu
dass er authentisch wirkt wir müssen
sehen bei den missbrauchsfällen der
lüfte hatte es einen ähnlichen effekt
gegeben bei diesem innenminister auch
dort war er sehr angefasst und
tatsächlich hat er dieses problem dann
angegangen oder ist er das angegangen
bei dem rechtsextremismus ist es so das
ist ja schon ähnliche vorfälle in
nordrhein westfalen gegeben hat bei der
polizei in hamm
das war im frühjahr da hat wohl
tatsächlich reagiert er hatte lokale
extremismus beauftragte eingesetzt denn
er hat heute gesagt vielleicht hat das
nicht gereicht
vielleicht haben wir da etwas übersehen
also ich würde jetzt zunächst mal ihm
zugestehen dass er da einen willen hat
das anzugehen
trotzdem gab es ja also es gab ja gibt
herne extremismus beauftragte wohl auch
der essener polizei die mit dem
polizeichefin nicht richtig informiert
bin liiert ist
sind das auch solche strukturen die
jetzt da sichtbar werden die auch
tatsächlich dann kritisiert werden von
opposition und von manchen aktivistinnen
man kann sagen glücklich ist das
sicherlich nicht es handelt sich
tatsächlich um die ehefrau des essener
polizeichefs das ist die extremismus
beauftragter des polizeipräsidiums essen
das war aber nicht geheim das ist in der
lokalen presse bereits in diesem
frühjahr thematisiert worden
darüber ist auch diskutiert worden und
das hat nicht dazu geführt dass die frau
abtreten muss es ist ja per se auch
nicht verboten es geht darum ob man ein
ausreichendes vertrauensverhältnis als
beamter als beamtin zu dieser
extremismus beauftragten hat auch wenn
man weiß dass hat die frau des aller
obersten chefs ist also glücklich ist es
bestimmt nicht aber verboten ist es auch
nicht und geheim war es nicht wie
würdest du die stimmung nach dem
westfalen jetzt beschreiben heute einen
tag nachdem das bekannt wurde ist das
etwas was tatsächlich das land auch
jetzt aufgerüttelt hat oder wird das von
vielen einfach nur zur kenntnis genommen
also ich glaube viele bürger sind schon
davon entsetzt das was sie da gehört
haben
ich muss sagen man kann sich das ja auch
schwer vorstellen es sind beamtinnen und
beamte zwischen 25 und 55 jahren oder
mit 20 mitte fünfzig frauen männer
darunter auch migranten und im grunde
genommen erinnert das ganze an einen
wirklich schlechten schülerstreich aber
das sind eben keine schüler das sind die
leute die das gesetz schützen und
durchsetzen sollen die auch über waffen
verfügen also selbst wenn sich
herausstellen sollte dass es sich nicht
um menschen handelt die beispielsweise
ich was ich jetzt geheime waffen
gebunkert haben und das land in die luft
jagen wollen
auch dann ist das komplett inakzeptabel
aber dann muss man eben auch damit
rechnen dass es möglicherweise noch viel
mehr sind als nur diese 29 die es eben
in mülheim geht wenn es so ist dass es
kein bewusstsein dafür gibt dass das was
dort geschehen ist absolut inakzeptabel
ist weil sich auch niemand in dieser
gruppe der nicht gepostet hat da
eingeschritten ist dann kann das problem
noch sehr viel größer seien als eben
diese 29 personen in mülheim
wenn wir noch mal kurz zur politik
schauen was ist denn jetzt die forderung
der opposition wie stellt die sich
darauf was hättet ihr jetzt gerne quasi
noch erledigt herbert reul hat ja auch
schon relativ viel aufs tablett gelegt
und gesagt hier werden wir jetzt tätig
die opposition fordert zunächst einmal
einen landesweiten extremismus
beauftragten und nicht nur lokal bei den
einzelnen polizei wir haben das ja
gerade gehört das kann in essen auch
schon mal ein bisschen zu nah dran sein
und das andere was die opposition
fordert ist eine unabhängige
wissenschaftliche studie
wir haben das ja mitbekommen was es auf
bundesebene gab die dass ich horst
seehofer gewährt hat eine studie über
racial profiling bei der polizei zu
machen auch herbert reul ist jetzt nicht
so dass er gesagt hat okay das ist das
allererste was wir unternehmen werden
ich vermute dass immer ein bisschen das
kalkül ist dass bei einer solchen
wissenschaftlichen studie ein
allgemeines urteil herauskommt dass
vielleicht viele dieser insgesamt 50.000
beschäftigten ein
in ein licht rückt in das man sie nicht
haben möchte
die opposition argumentiert bei einer
wissenschaftlichen aufarbeitung sei noch
niemand dümmer geworden und deswegen
brauche man die dringend wieso gibt es
bisher noch niemanden der sich quasi
landesweit um so ein problem kümmert es
gibt hier in anderen bundesländern also
es ist zumindest dabei zu geben also ob
leute zu geben an die man sich wenden
kann wenn man merkt hier gibt es
schwierigkeiten wie wird das in nrw
begründet dass da noch keine
landesweiten bemühungen entstanden sind
naja ich glaube das bewusstsein für
dieses problem wächst erst allmählich
wir haben das ja gesehen auch die
vorfälle in hessen das ist alles
innerhalb des letzten jahres war
innerhalb von jahresfrist
die polizeischüler in bayern und in
nordrhein-westfalen was in der ersten
hälfte dieses jahres dass diese vorfälle
in hamm bekannt geworden sind
es ist etwas geschehen aber das war kein
thema worüber man vor drei oder fünf
jahren gesprochen hat auch wenn man
jetzt zur kenntnis nehmen muss dass
diese gruppen eben auch schon vor drei
oder fünf jahren bestanden haben
er hat sich offenbar etwas
verselbständigt dass man nicht zur
kenntnis genommen hat und dass man eben
jetzt zur kenntnis nimmt und jetzt
versucht man eben auch zu reagieren
also liebe zuschauer ich habe jetzt ganz
viele fragen hier die meiner kollegin
dort aber nicht beantworten kann weil
sie keine kriminologin ist die sollten
eigentlich an tobias singelnstein
professor von der uni dortmund gehen der
musste sich leider schon verabschieden
weil das doch ein bisschen länger
gedauert hat bis herbert reul an die
mikrofone treten konnte als wir gedacht
haben der ist heute ein viel gefragter
mann aber eine frage dort kann ich an
dich weitergeben
hier wurde nämlich gefragt gibt es
eigentlich keine linksextremen chats
also ist da schon irgendwas in nrw
aufgeflogen man sagt das geht nicht in
rechte richtung rechtsextremismus
sondern in die richtung linksextremismus
nein es ist nicht aufgeflogen
wir müssen wir sehen das hat herbert
reul gerade mehrfach betont es ist eben
sehr sehr schwer an diese privaten chat
gruppen überhaupt heranzukommen
diese ist ja nur durch einen zufall
sozusagen aufgeflogen weil man eben ein
handy aus anderen gründen untersucht hat
und dabei eben auf diese private chat
kopf gestoßen ist aber wenn etwas
auffällt müssen wir noch fest
dann sind es immer rechtsradikaler oder
rechtsextreme tendenzen oder ist
irgendwas anderes bekannt also mir ist
nichts anderes bekannt ich will mal so
ein bisschen die logik erläutern die
polizisten die sind in einem schwer
belasteten beruf tätig das heißt die
kommen immer dann zum einsatz wenn
irgendwo eine straftat passiert ist ein
konflikt geschehen ist etwas unangenehm
ist dass die anfälligkeit dort für
rechtsextreme tendenzen möglicherweise
größer ist als für linksextreme
tendenzen kann durchaus sein
allgemein ist die polizei oder ich sage
mal organisationen mit chor greift ihr
weniger bekannt für linksextremismus da
müsste man vielleicht eher in einem
anarchistischen spektrum suchen
also das ist aber nur so eine allgemeine
beobachtung die ich da äußere also diese
gesamte logik von rechtsextremismus ja
eher law and order mann orientiert sich
an jemandem der nach vorne geht und
stärker ist man setzt das dann auch mit
gewalt durch weil das er zur polizei
passt kannst du ja das ist sozusagen die
vermutung
mir ist bislang nichts bekannt was von
linksextremismus innerhalb der polizei
vorfälle oder ähnliches dass die bekannt
geworden sind
rechtsextremistische vorfälle aber eben
durchaus gut ich bedanke mich dort für
die ersten eindrücke vom landtag nrw und
für die zusammenfassung der stimmung im
land wie gesagt viele fragen die jetzt
aufgebracht sind können wir leider jetzt
nicht so richtig beantworten ich fast
noch ein bisschen zusammen was herbert
reul gerade gesagt hat der nrw
innenminister hat sich vor dem landtag
nrw geäußert zu den vorfällen oder zu
den erkenntnissen die die polizei in
nordrhein westfalen jetzt gesammelt hat
da ist quasi durch zufall aufgefallen
dass es eine whatsapp jet gruppe gab
mit mittlerweile 30 beschuldigten die
sich dort beteiligt haben oder zumindest
drinnen waren dort wurden rechtsextreme
nachrichten bilder ausgetauscht die alle
wohl straff fähig sind
14 polizisten wurden suspendiert aus dem
dienst sofort entfernt und 100 weitere
medien hat die polizei jetzt wohl fest
stellt also fest im eingesammelt
sichergestellt dass das richtige wort
zur richtigen medien laptops pcs tablet
sim-karten handys festplatten die werden
jetzt alle ausgewertet herbert reul
zeigte sich gestern schon sehr betroffen
heute vom landtag auch sehr betroffen
und hat jetzt gesagt ja wir jetzt
handeln
ich will gegen einen falschen corner ist
vorgehen das wird einen neuen
sonderbeauftragten für
rechtsextremistische tendenzen der
polizei gehen und der wind nicht mehr
diskutieren und nicht lamentieren
sondern handeln und wenn ich jetzt noch
einmal hier auf unser kommentar schied
gucke dann gab es eine frage wie viel
waren das in diesem chat wie gesagt
bekannt sind zurzeit 30 beteiligte dann
geht es einen kommentar von gerd 66 der
sagt das kernproblem besteht darin wer
sich bei der polizei bewirbt das ist nun
mal nicht der querschnitt der
bevölkerung sondern der rechte teil
davon
das ist eine behauptung zum beispiel die
kann ich nicht so richtig verifizieren
das ist eine vermutung aber auch meine
kollegin dort verbrachte gerade gesagt
wenn man in diese richtung tendiert geht
man eher in die polizei als in eine
anarchistische gruppe dann gibt es die
frage wie sieht ihr diese profile diese
personen gedeckt und geschützt haben von
gürkan aksoy auf facebook auch das ist
alles noch unbekannt
das ist eben das problem dass herbert
reul ansprache seine geschätzt eine
geschützte jet gruppe gewesen wo nicht
jeder rein kam und dann muss man halt
davon ausgehen dass die menschen aber
die beteiligten leute ziemlich genau
wussten dass das was sie da tun nicht
richtig legales und dann wahrscheinlich
lieber in den dienststellen darüber
stillschweigen bewahrt haben
pocher ist ja klar meint auf facebook
woche sind keine einzelfälle die anzahl
und vernetzung deuten eher auf ein
strukturelles problem hin da kann ich
dazu sagen das hat innenminister herbert
reul von der cdu gestern auch schon
eingeräumt hat gesagt er kann nicht mehr
von einzelfällen sprechen das ist für
den cdu minister schon relativ
bemerkenswert und dann gab es eine
weitere vom selben user ops untersucht
werden wird in welchen fällen die
beschuldigten polizistinnen eventuell
auch bürger innen mit
migrationshintergrund den dienst unrecht
getan haben auch dazu können wir noch
nicht sagen
sein laufendes ermittlungsverfahren es
kann sein dass da ganz in den ganzen
sachen noch mehr herauskommt aber da
innenminister herbert reul die in der
öffentlichkeit sehr früh informiert hat
also quasi dann wenn als sie die ersten
gerichtsfesten sachen hatten
kann es sein dass in den nächsten
monaten da noch mehr
kommt wir werden auf jeden fall das
thema im blick behalten wir können davon
ausgehen dass das thema rechtsextreme
oder rechtsradikale rassistische
strukturen in der polizei generell in
deutschland uns weiter beschäftigen wird
weil dort auch jetzt vielmehr hingeguckt
wird herbert roller hat das gesagt das
ist wichtig da hin zu gucken und je
genauer man hinguckt desto mehr findet
man natürlich auch und wir können auch
gespannt sein die zehn minister also
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer dazu
äußern wird ob er sich dazu äußert er
hat hier eine studie zur rachel
profiling abgelehnt erst mal und damit
machen wir jetzt erstmal diesen stream
zu und bedanken uns fürs zuschauen und
für eure kommentare und sagen bis zum
nächsten mal
und tschüss